[Music]
day three cast off from the Royal Palace
sailing upriver towards Torah spend the
night there day four cast off from Torah
morning sail down river towards Akkad
Kofu spend the night day five
cast off from Torah in the afternoon
sailed towards a cat Khufu day six cast
off from a cocoon sail upriver towards
Torah day seven cast off in the morning
gay eight cast off in the morning from
Torah sailed down river towards a Kiku
fruit spend the night there day nine
cast off in the morning from a Kiku foo
sail upriver spend the night day ten
cast off from Torah more in a kakuzu day
eleven inspector Marrero spends the day
with his file carrying out works related
to the dye cover goshi Khufu day 12
inspector Moreira spends the day with
his file carrying out works related to
the daikon oroshi Khufu day 13
inspector Moreira spends the day with
his file at the dike which is in oroshi
Khufu day 14 inspector Murray spent the
day with his file on the dike of Roshi
Khufu
day 25 inspector Murray spends the day
with his file
holding stones into her south spent the
night it to her south day 26
inspector Moreira casts off with his
file from tourist south loaded with
stone bracket Khufu spends the night at
she Khufu day 27 set sail from she Khufu
sails towards a key Khufu loaded with
stone spends the night at IKEA Kofu day
28 casts off Rebecca cuckoo in the
morning sells upriver towards to her
south day 29 inspector Marrero spent the
day with his file
hauling stones in Tora South spent the
night in to her south day 30 inspector
where spent the day with his file
hauling stones in tourist South spent
the night in to herself first day of the
month the director of each year casts
off her hello police in a transport boat
to bring us food from hailey ah police
while the elite is in Tora day 2
inspector Murray spends the day with his
file
hauling stones into her North spends the
night at Tora north day 3 inspector
Maria caste self from Turin north sails
towards a Katyusha loaded with stone
therefore the director or Vidya comes
back from Heliopolis with 40 sacks and a
large measure of bread while the elite
Paul stones in Tora North
day five inspector my rear spends the
day with his file loading stones onto
the boats of the elite into the north
spends the night at torah day six
inspector my rare sets sail with a boat
of the naval section of the file of
tower going downriver towards a kid who
spends the night at Roshi Khufu day
seven set sail in the morning towards a
Kiku Fuu sails towing the boats towards
Turin orth
day 8 sets sail from Roshi Khufu sails
towards Tora north
inspector Marrero spends the day with a
boat of tower day 13
spends the night to her south day 14
hauling stones spends the night in Tora
South day fifteen inspector Moreau
spends the day with his file
hauling stones into herself spends the
night in to her south day 16 inspector
Mayer spent the day with his file
loading Lee boats with stones sails
downriver spends the night at XI Khufu
[Music]
day 20 inspector Moreira spends the day
with his file hauling stones into her
south Lodz five craft spends the night
at Torah day 21 inspector Murray spends
the day with his file loading a
transport ship at Torah north set sail
from Torah in the afternoon day 22
spends the night at Roshi Khufu in the
morning sets sail from Roshi Khufu sails
towards a Kaku Fuu spend the night at
the Chapel of Akkad Khufu day 23 the
director of 10sc spends the day with his
naval section in a row sheet Khufu
because the decision to cast off was
taken spend the night of Roshi Khufu day
24 inspector Maria spends the day with
his file hauling stones with those who
are on the register of the elite the a
pro teams and the noble and CAF director
of Roshi Khufu day 25 inspector Maria
spent the day with his team hauling
stones and tora spends the night at Tora
north
you